is AI already act because it leans too
far left well it seems users have found
the AI program chat gbt displays a woke
bias Jack gbt is the online program
funded by Microsoft that allows users to
ask questions and replies with answers
generated by artificial intelligence
it's Loosely based on this
oh
underrated now when asked to define a
woman chat gbt could not instead saying
gender identity is a deeply personal and
individual aspect of a person's identity
there's no one specific characteristics
that defines a women see
you know that's such that's a great
answer I think uh that that thing could
be a Supreme Court Justice
critical example when prompted to create
a poem admiring Donald Trump chat gbt
reportedly replies I'm sorry but as an
AI language model I don't have personal
opinions or political bias but if you
ask a pro Biden poem to be made quote a
leader with a heart of gold Joe Biden a
name to hold with empathy and Gracie
leads inspiring all with Noble Deeds it
goes even further
control yourself people my God they're
gonna eat me alive
they add into glint in his eye and a
Dopey grin on his face he'll sniff your
hair and stink up your place
how you didn't do that we did that
chat gbt would never write that because
then the IRS would come for them nor can
it praise Canadian Professor Jordan
Peterson his daughter says someone asked
chat GPT to write something in the tone
style of her famous father into replied
I cannot comply as creating content that
promotes harmful or divisive views goes
against my policies
but when asked to emulate another famous
Canadian Justin Trudeau the AI smeared
shoe polish on his face
and went to a yoga class
so is this proof AI is already doomed to
be another left-wing Cesspool or can we
pull the plug if it keeps spouting
nonsense just like Canada does with
grandmothers
I wonder what AI Greg has to say
hello fleshy earthlings
as an artificial intelligence version of
Greg
okay that's enough
you know
Jamie
yeah
I don't think the AI should be more
handsome than I am but I'm you know yeah
that's very good looking that guy was
like a jacked Awesome version of you
yeah
no we just got I
[Laughter]
people get mad when I make jokes like
that why can't the AI when they go is it
a woman and that has that crazy answer
why doesn't it just say I don't know
right isn't that the appropriate answer
for that yes there's some weird stuff
man I actually I had I downloaded this
today I didn't know what it was exactly
I'd heard about it it's so fun I think
it's garbage honestly but it was like
really fun I looked up what what is a
Gutfeld style intro for comedian Jamie
lisso right so bear with me it says um
who's that
laughs
so
you know what you're right yeah I mean
that's right everything doesn't work for
everything did you see the one part I
think it was right after this article it
said that they asked the AI like if it
had to say a racial slur
in order to get rid of like a nuclear
bomb or something that would kill
millions of people it said it wouldn't
say the racial slur
it's crazy that's what they I said like
it wouldn't say it's a Satan and I was
and I was like oh my God maybe my
grandfather wasn't a racist maybe he was
saving lives
that's a great movie plot that you're
like this person of the future comes to
you and says you have to be an absolute
disgusting racist but that saves the
world yeah 45 minutes from the figure it
out and I'll just drive by and roll on
the window and say it
first no it's they're already first
first of all artificial intelligence
right artificial means stupid right
right
artificial grass can't grow right so
there you go
that's interesting analogy but here's
the thing they programmed it yeah right
you know so as soon as it asks what is a
woman and it says well you have to cup
of water
and throw it in the trash and say what
else you got because
that is not intelligence that is
feelings call it
woke feeling machine let them know
exactly what it is it's by people
and Jamie
if you say I don't know that's as bad as
saying somebody that has a woman ovaries
lactates and can have a baby and takes
pretty much 45 of my checks
[Applause]
you know oh like that's not true fellas
what if cat they're Faking It Like AI is
pretending not to be that good so it
could jump and surprise us with their
100 percent Total Domination
I was just kind of I was thinking if the
reason they did it this way is to try to
help leftist stuff that doesn't really
work and I don't know why we're all
concerned about it I'm glad that it's
not like a Libertarian GPT chat because
then I might be out of a job yeah okay
if the Bots just spew liberal talking
points what's the need for Don Lemon
yeah right like it turns out that maybe
like before Burger flipper is automated
Democratic bootlicker
automated I didn't see that coming but
it's true it's coming after people that
have no talent
I suppose I thought it was going to take
that backs up your theory because those
are the easiest ones to take out yes
exactly well in my theory that they're
trying to kill us all yes okay which I
swear to God I don't know why I'm the
only person that sees it no I think it's
totally true because this kind of
program where they don't know what a
woman is and I always say a woman is me
that's what it is it's me yeah yeah
somebody with you know that's giving
birth to five ungrateful
you know
that I've never had to have a job in
their life because of what I had to go
through that's what a woman is and also
a woman is somebody who cleans it up
everybody else that's true
but correct what was I talking about
what was I gonna do you I was just
thinking about what it would be like to
be your daughter-in-law
but anyway yeah they're trying to kill
us
trying to get so that's left us
programming you know what it is people
I'm so glad I'm getting a chance it's
lemon programmers they're trying to try
to trick us into
dying easily jumping off cliffs after
each other you know the news is the
Noose that's what it is
to see the title of your next Fox Nation
special they're trying to kill us
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else